now the story of a young man teaching
math to the world NewsHour correspondent
Spencer Michels reports so this is a a
quadratic equation essentially we're
trying to find the zeros of this
disembodied voice is heard every day by
tens of thousands of students struggling
with math both in the US and around the
world so what is x squared plus 4x plus
4 well X its X plus 2 times X plus 2
my first thirty-three-year-old Salman
Khan recently quit his job as a hedge
fund analyst to devote himself to an
unpaid job teaching math on the Internet
welcome to the presentation on basic
addition these are cancers or cancer
cells is the investors in the
mortgage-backed securities he has posted
1,200 lessons on YouTube which appear on
an electronics blackboard an arranged in
subject from basic addition and advanced
calculus to science and finance and they
are free introduction to trigonometry is
I teach people about the trig functions
this is one of the more popular videos
this has 179 thousand views and you know
this is just what what sine cosine and
tangent are Khan lives in California's
Silicon Valley with his wife a
Rheumatologist in training at Stanford
and their new baby he got the idea for
Khan Academy four years ago when he
taught a young cousin how to convert
kilograms to grams many American
students have trouble with math studies
show they lag behind their counterparts
in Asia and Europe in both math and
science with Khan's help his cousin got
good at math and he eventually had a
career tapping into anxieties around the
world now he records his lessons from a
converted closet in the back of his
bedroom he never goes on camera kind of
feels like the voice in their head
you're looking at it it kind of feels
like someone's over your shoulder
talking in your ear as opposed to
someone at a blackboard that's distant
from you sorry for starting the
presentation with a cough but now I want
to continue with the 45-45-90
angles although he is not the first
person to teach on the Internet his
simple operation has attracted more
eyeballs than most university sites and
his fame has spread the old girl caste
Alea school in Palo Alto invited Khan to
speak and he immediately connected to
the student body you tell me that you
really don't know how you know dividing
decimals is still kind of this little
gray area and if dividing decimals
actually is you're not alone dividing
decimals is kind of the one thing that
no one wants to admit that they kind of
forgot how to do he exuded pride in his
expanding online audience more and more
people are kept watching it and now it's
reaching actually on the order of about
a hundred thousand students now a month
and a forty thousand video views a day
it was the concept of short repeatable
lessons that attracted high school
senior bridgid meaning who admitted
she'd had trouble with 7th grade algebra
I think the teachers are good but they
can't go out of pace that's like perfect
for everyone but I like the concept of
knowing something in class but then
going back and pressing pause or rewind
and actually getting a deeper
understanding of it shy students who
don't ask questions in class may benefit
the most from Khan's videos says
Kimberly Knapp who teaches math at
castilleja but his lessons aren't a
substitute for the classroom fix I don't
think that there's a perfect replacement
for the work that we do in just the kind
of conversations that students and
teachers engage in together but Khan
thinks maybe lecture halls and
classrooms have their limitations
originally he kept his lessons short
because of YouTube restrictions now he
thinks short is better
I've got researchers telling me that you
don't realize 10 minutes we've done
studies is how long someone can have a
high level of concentration and anything
beyond that you kind of lose it and I
think we've all had that experience in
sitting in college where you're can be
with the professor for about 10 15
minutes and then you kind of lose it a
lot of math students apparently agree
I talked via the internet with Cody
Woodward in Anchorage Alaska who uses
Khan's lessons at college
has helped me immensely in the grades
for my math classes and I've also
learned a lot Internet instruction be at
the Khan Academy or taped university
lectures could revolutionize education
in remote third-world locations where
access to high-quality instruction is
frequently unavailable that's the hope
of Neil radhiya a young software
programmer at Cisco Systems he and
fellow volunteers at world possible
working on their vacations are bringing
online teaching to Africa and India for
starters when radhiya and Megha Jane
first traveled to Ethiopia they found
thousands of brand-new computers sitting
idle because they couldn't connect to
the internet and therefore couldn't get
online instruction the great thing to do
would to be putting a lot of these
resources on a single local server that
we could bring to the colleges to the
universities to community centers we
came across the Kahn Academy and we
emailed him and asked him if we could
reproduce some of his material on our
servers and he was very willing to help
us out you'd be surprised how fast these
kids learn and pick these things up so
it isn't strange to them they've heard
of this and they are excited to use it
for Kahn teaching math and science and
Finance is just the beginning he's ready
to expand his YouTube site to include
whatever strikes his fancy I want to do
everything I want to do history I want
to do grammar I want to do literally
every every subject so far except for a
little advertising revenue he is
donating his time and equipment it's a
one-man operation but it's gotten so big
he expects to start soliciting outside
support to keep his academy growth